>> Tucker: THE NATION’S CHOP
IS NEARLY A WEEK OLD NOW AND
STILL SURPRISINGLY LITTLE IS
KNOWN ABOUT CHOP.
AS THE NATION PEACEFUL OR IS IT
DANGEROUS?
IS A PROSPEROUS OR IMPOVERISHED?
IS IT FRIENDLY OR HOSTILE?
LOOK ON NORTH KOREA ON PUGET
SOUND, WE CAN ONLY GUESS.
WE HAVE ONE TOUCH FOR A TONIGHT,
OUR OWN KYLE ROTHENBERG VENTURED
INTO THE NATION FORMALLY KNOWN
AS DOWNTOWN SEATTLE.
HERE’S WHAT HE FOUND.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: SO THERE IT IS,
DOCUMENTARY EVIDENCE OF LIFE
INSIDE B19.
GOING ABOUT THEIR BUSINESS, WE
SHOULD WARN YOU, THOUGH, WHAT
YOU JUST SAW IS JUST A SNAPSHOT,
THE NATION OF CHOP IS DYNAMIC,
CHANGING EVEN AS WE WATCH.
FOR ONE THING, IT’S GETTING
SMALLER.
TODAY CHOP WAS PARTITIONED BY
THE CITY OF SEATTLE, SEATED
SEVERAL BLOCKS BACK TO ITS
FORMER OVERLORDS.
IN RETURN, THE COUNTRY’S
MAKESHIFT BARRIERS ARE BEING
REPLACED WITH SOLID CONCRETE
BLOCKS BECAUSE NOTHING SAYS
COUNTRY MORE QUICKLY THAN A
BORDER.
OUR MAN ON THE GROUND OUTSIDE
THE NATION OF CHOP, JOINS US
TONIGHT.
I SEE THEY’VE BEEFED UP THEIR
BORDER SECURITY.
>> THEY HAVE ALL OF THE CITY HAS
DECIDED TO BEEF UP THE BORDER
SECURITY, NOT NECESSARILY THOSE
LIVING IN CHOP.
THE MAYOR OF SEATTLE MADE THE
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT ESSENTIALLY
THEY CAME TO SOME KIND OF
COMPROMISE, A TYPICAL
NEO-RONALD REAGAN SITUATION,
EMERGENCY VEHICLES AND PEOPLE
WHO ACTUALLY LIVE AND DRIVE
THERE CAN ACTUALLY GET THROUGH
BECAUSE REMEMBER, CHOP HAPPENS
TO BE IN A SPACE WHERE A LOT OF
PEOPLE LIVE AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
WORK.
HOWEVER, SINCE WE ARE DEALING
WITH AN ORGANIZATION THAT ISN’T
REALLY AN ORGANIZATION, THERE IS
NOT REALLY ONE LEADER SO THE
COMPROMISE TOWARDS THE LAST HOUR
OR SO THAT STARTED TO BREAK UP A
LITTLE BIT, SOME FOLKS ARE ANGRY
THAT THEY’D GIVEN UP A LITTLE
BIT TOO MUCH, WE ARE HEARING
RUMORS THAT THERE’S GOING TO BE
ANOTHER MARCH TOWARDS WEST’S
PRECINCTS, ABOUT A TEN MINUTE
WALK FROM WHERE THEY CURRENTLY
ARE, ANOTHER POLICE STATION THAT
PRESUMABLY THEY’D LIKE TO EITHER
TAKE OVER OR AT LEAST USED TO
GET THEIR ACTIVISM OUT THERE SO
CONSIDER THIS MANIFEST DESTINY
OF SOME KIND, THEY WILL BE ON
THE MOVE AND MAYBE GET US SOME
MORE LAND.
>> Tucker: IF ONLY MARGARET
MEAD WERE HERE.
I WANT TO ASK YOU AN OPEN-ENDED
QUESTION, YOUR BEST ESTIMATE,
ONE PERCENTAGEWHAT PERCENTAGE AR
GIVEN TIME?
>> I DON’T EVEN KNOW HOW TO
BEGIN?
WE ARE NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT
ALCOHOL, CORRECT?
YOU KNOW, THERE IS DEFINITELY A
POPULATION -- NOT EVERYBODY
THERE IS GOING TO BE HIGH OR
DRUNK AT THE SAME TIME, I WILL
BE FAIR TO THEM BUT THERE IS
DEFINITELY A HIGH PERCENTAGE OF
FOLKS WHO ARE HAVING A GOOD TIME
AND ACTUALLY, THAT’S WHERE SOME
OF THE ANGER HAS COME FROM, SOME
OF THE ACTIVISTS WHO ARE THERE
BECAUSE THEY ARE TRYING TO
CHANGE POLICY SO THEY GOT A LOT
OF PEOPLE ESSENTIALLY JUST
SHOWING UP FOR A PARTY, TREATING
THIS AS A TOURIST DESTINATION,
HANGING OUT AND EATING
SANDWICHES AND GRANOLA AND
HAVING A GOOD OLD TIME ON OTHER
PEOPLE ARE SAYING, HEY --
PRIMARILY WHITE PEOPLE ARE DOING
THIS, COULD YOU MAYBE GET BACK
TO THE WHOLE ACTIVISM THING WERE
HERE FOR?
THERE IS SOME INNER STRUGGLE.
>> Tucker: IT’S ALWAYS
RIPPLING BENEATH THE SURFACE IN